cette semaine à l'espace philippe noiret
je vous propose un événement
exceptionnel donc ce samedi à 14 heures
ça commence par une projection avec un
programme de courts métrages liberté 13
films poème c'est la collection en
sortant de l'école donc qui a déjà
produit des des programmes sur des
poésies
donc voilà c'est des films poèmes et là
c'est sur la poésie de paul eluard donc
13 13 courts métrages pour treize jeunes
réalisateurs issus des écoles
d'animation
voilà nous mettre vraiment en avant la
poésie du delwart et joue avec avec
plein de techniques d'animation
différentes et plein de ton aussi devant
la de récits très différent très variés
et c'est l'occasion d'accueillir une
peau est donc la peau est pascal petit
qui vient nous proposer un atelier
d'écriture de poésie etc offerts par les
itinéraires poétique
donc c'est accessible à partir de 6 7
ans et c'est aussi pour les adultes
donc n'hésitez pas et en plus vous aurez
un goûter donc ce samedi à 14 heures à
l'espace philippe noiret
[Musique]